an Alaska Airlines flight was going from
uh Oregon to California and it takes off
this is a 737 Max 9 it's gaining
altitude I think it was about 16,000 ft
and the passengers hear a bang they
thought it was an explosion and part of
a part of a door like part of the side
of the plane explodes it just pops out
some some person's shirt is just ripped
off of him a little teddy bear goes
flying out the
window what the was that and they
need to make an emergency landing
luckily no one died but you can see some
of the pictures of it it's crazy it's
not even just that a window popped out
it's like a whole little side of the
plane pops out there how does this kind
of thing happen
because forgetting about high philosophy
and political
ideology we are no longer good at doing
just the basic things to make a society
run